se mire en una guerra de reglas hay
leyes que son están basadas en las
convenciones de ginebra y um
una norma básica en un conflicto armado
es que no se puede maltratar ni se puede
torturar a prisioneros de guerra
nosotros analizamos estos vídeos
que han aparecido públicamente y que
muestran precisamente eso a soldados
detenidos que están desarmados que están
que están que están inmovilizados y que
el soldados con uniformes que parecen
ser ucranianos les disparan en la pierna
a tres de ellos
en nuestro trabajo ha sido localizar el
lugar hemos identificado
elementos en los vídeos que muestran que
probablemente se produjo en un pueblo
cercano garcía jarquín y hemos analizado
las heridas con la ayuda de un
traumatólogo y también hemos analizado
el audio de el acento de las personas
que hablan etcétera y realmente es un
hecho muy grave que debe ser investigado
como un posible crimen de guerra y más
allá de estos vídeos difundidos en las
redes sociales tienen más información
sobre actos similares por parte de las
tropas ucranianas y qué acciones se
pueden llevar a cabo para frenarlos
este es el vídeo del incidente más grave
que hemos podido documentar pues de
soldados que han sufrido disparos cuando
estaban inmovilizados
también hemos visto como
el gobierno ucraniano ha usado
en redes sociales oficiales para
distribuir vídeos de soldados rusos
detenidos en los que estos soldados se
les pide que digan el nombre de su
familia a su dirección en rusia ese tipo
de vídeos también está prohibido por la
convención de ginebra porque la
convención establece que los
los prisioneros de guerra tienen que ser
tratados de forma digna y humana
entonces este también es en una
violación de la convención lo que yo
diría aparte de estos hechos donde vemos
a las fuerzas ucranianas cometiendo
posibles crímenes de guerra es que hemos
documentado un enorme número de casos
donde son las tropas rusas las que están
cometiendo posibles crímenes de guerra
especialmente por el uso discriminado de
munición contra civiles que es un hecho
gravísimo y que ha provocado muchas
muertes
precisamente por estado le quería
preguntar por posibles acciones como
estas cometidas por las tropas rusas
pero que podemos hacer desde el ámbito
internacional para frenar este tipo de
actos o simplemente son los gobiernos de
una y otra parte los que pueden actuar
si bueno obviamente el que es
responsable
digamos de esas fuerzas que pueden estar
cometiendo crímenes de guerra tiene
tiene que acatar la ley internacional
sea la convención del cine verán
entonces digamos nuestro llamamiento es
a los al gobierno ucraniano y al
gobierno ruso que repito
posiblemente ha cometido actos
gravísimos
crímenes de guerra gravísimos
tenemos la ventaja algo muy positivo es
que la corte penal internacional ha
abierto una investigación sobre el
conflicto craneal
un ruso ucraniano y debe investigar
todos los crímenes de guerra por
cualquiera de las partes entonces es muy
importante que lo haga a conciencia y es
muy importante también el trabajo de
verificación que nosotros hacemos y
otras organizaciones para proporcionar
evidencias para esa corte internacional